[Music]
there's bathroom scenes shower scenes
are you comfortable you gotta be you
know pretty exposed and some of those
scenes I know I'm saying that because
I'm you know hyper ashamed of ever being
naked around anybody yeah not alone I
don't get naked
how are you comfortable with it you know
I say this I am a a private nudist so I
love walk around my house all the time
in the nude but in public I don't know
in a few times I've been asked on set to
you know get down a little bit more into
my skivvies and I'm like I don't see the
TV titties what are the TV - okay well
in as you guys know that my girl tasty
on the show she talks about TV titties
and TV titties my litmus test is this oh
can I see this pencil for a second sure
so that the test is if you can take a
pencil
lady's and you can place it up under
your tent and if it falls then you have
TV titties meaning you can wear like a
size a cup you can be around and if
people aren't gonna like go that's the
kind of thing that you see got at you
but if I can hold the pencil under there
you see like mine
[Applause]
is favorite and I was just retrieving my
property if they were to be unleashed on
television you know the pause button
would be like hitting well mainly
because they'd be like are those anyone
got a pencil I got one I mean women who
you know carry these you know these
become excellent pockets yeah I didn't
know that yes you can hide I've hidden
phones I've hidden money I've hidden yes
doesn't clap it up
[Applause]
take a thermos out keep your hands warm
when they're cold you know it's a lot
I'm learning so much right now
anytime anytime
you